welcome back time for didn't we need a
thing Friday follies we need a little
thing we need what do you call it a
thing we need to the time okay we start
with a chairman of Starbucks announcing
a new bathroom policy for all its stores
what could possibly go wrong here to
explain it all is New York Times
bestselling author the will Wilder
series and Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo Starbucks opening its bathroom
well remember back in April that
controversy those two african-american
men they were evicted not allowed to use
the bathroom because they didn't buy
anything well now how he schultz
chairman of Starbucks has announced a
new policy we don't want to become a
public bathroom but we're gonna make the
right decision 100% of the time and give
people the key because we don't want
anyone Starbucks to feel as if we are
not giving access to you to the bathroom
because you are less than we want you to
be more than so let me just get this
straight
so we know what hat when you go running
on the mall here in Washington you go to
the public um you get the drinking
fountains when I was training for the
marathon years ago the people would be
cleaning their socks in the and so you
would desperate for water and then you'd
see someone cleaning their socks god
bless them but you don't want to drink
when the socks are being you know wrung
out
well that's gonna be happening we're not
going to be a public bathroom but you
are going to be a public bathroom you're
giving the keys to everybody a hundred
percent of the time I've spoken to start
with managers in the last few days they
say it's a health nuisance they have to
go with like the hazmat outfits to clean
out these bathrooms and people they not
only clean their articles they clean
themselves in the same so that's a
problem you attract the homeless and you
drive away paying miles they're gonna
lose customers what have you rather go
to Pete's one of you heard your radio
callers had a great idea rather than
having this 8,000 store unconscious bias
training at the end of May the better
idea might be put public stalls and
bathrooms in the back of every Starbucks
in an urban setting and then you know
you could call that unconscious common
sense that would be a good say okay well
I just like what he said we don't want
you to feel like you're less than we
want you to be
more than can we make up those t-shirts
that is a deep thoughts from Schultz
free room no doubt we got mad Maxine
okay Mad Max one of my favorites mad
Maxine Maxine Waters we have to play she
was upset about this is an Obama era
anti racism a thing for car dealerships
the Republicans repealed it she went on
a tear we are trying to make sure that
we're making America great every day in
every way and the best way to do that is
to stop talking about discrimination and
start talking about the nation we're
coming together as a people in spite of
what you say mr. Kelly please do not
leave because I want you to know that I
am more offended as an african-american
woman than you will ever be and this
business about making America great
again it is your president that's
dividing this country I resent the
remark about making America great again
he's down here making a speech for this
dishonorable President of the United
States of America having said that I
reserve the balance of my time you know
I do not yield not once not one second
not one second to you I'm not using a
second to you this is my favorite G not
a second you know I love I wish Maxine
Waters would get engaged and really
collaborate with the Republicans have
the majority come on
no she agrees with them on some issues
work with my and disagree with them on
the other issues insurance health care
chicken finds to collaborate yeah little
act that was dishonorable that was that
was close rules and it goes like oh we
got racist Legos now quickly 30 makes
it's like Megan Markel who's part of the
royal wedding the party's no bride they
have created a Lego at Legoland in
Windsor they're saying it's racist
because she's not dark enough look she
has the same skin tone as Prince Harry
so they're saying this is outrageous
I actually went and studied and found
people saying the Incredible Hulk was
lime green in his Lego depiction some of
the people who collect these things
he's lime green and in the Avengers
movie sees dark green we need to be
consistent this is so ridiculous Lego
has also been charged with racism
in the past there was a job of the Hut
playset they said it looked like the
Hagia Sophia in Turkey oh yeah I guess
yeah and he was he he smoked a hookah
and that was a problem so look at this
so they were called that Lego said now
Laura I'm breaking news here what I
called Lego they are doing an entire Fox
set of playsets this year and the
Ingraham angle is one of them
they sent me the first two Legos in the
collection this is from the Ingraham
angle collection we'll put it up on the
screen this is you and I just look at
the fact look look I do I have orange
hair and you have big ears they have a
full screen of this I look like Tron
there it is look look like a female
Donald Trump where that's me I have to
say I'm very upset about these
depictions because my ears look nothing
like that but I can see the likeness in
your little lighter than that I'm
finding that there's there's inherent
bias and implicit bias and up against
against natural blondes I take back the
balance of my time
I'm not a minute get out where's my
gavel
thanks Raymond